like that is focused as a laser right
that has dispersed merely lights the
room you can cut metal with a laser you
can do surgery with a laser and a life
that is laser focused generally becomes
very successful in the area that it is
focused on life and light share that so
focus your life on something the young
man they called earlier had a point
there is a lot of people sadly running
around America that believe that money
and wealth are evil and that wealthy
people are all evil these are people
that have not been exposed to enough of
the world number one but number two they
have an improper reading of scripture
meaning they're wrong some of the most
godly people on the planet that I've
ever met are very very wealthy however
they don't view themselves as wealthy
they view themselves as what we
Christians call a steward a manager of
God's assets and we're managing it for
his glory at his direction and he is the
owner and so no I don't believe in
getting rich for getting rich sake I
believe in building wealth because it is
biblical to do so in the house of the
wise our stores of choice food and oil
but a foolish man devours all he has you
spend everything you make you're a fool
and that's by the way how you end up
broke and broke is not spiritual by the
way rich is not spiritual spiritual is
spiritual loving God is not proven by
being poor and loving God is not proven
by being wealthy you simply love God
that's spiritual
and you know you can decide to do that
at any economic strata but then if I'm
going to follow that are the basic
tenants of Scripture which is a cause
and effect world that we live in
if you plant corn you will grow corn the
Bible says as you sow so shall you reap
what you plant as you plant so you know
and so if you do dumb things you're
gonna get dumb and desperate results in
your life I've done dumb things having
some of you it doesn't work out well
that's why we quit doing them because
they were dumb and if I save no money
every time I have any kind of a bump in
the road everything around me is a
crisis how is that godly being Poor's
makes you godly that has nowhere in
scripture now it is in the liberal
ideology that the wealthier evil and
should be punished and taxed extra and
thus the whole wealth inequality
movement and the the whole socialism
movement and all of that stuff but
that's a political ideology that's not a
Christian ideology and conservatives
aren't applet they're it's a political
ideology that's not a Christian ideology
so what you've got to do is you can't as
my pastor says you can't let the world
teach you theology you have to read the
scriptures and say this is what they say
and this is how I'm going to live wealth
is not evil are some wealthy people evil
yes
absolutely did they become wealthy
because they were evil in some cases
they're crooks in some cases are just
evil people they got rich sometimes that
happens are their wealthy people that
are godly people absolutely everywhere
I know hundreds if not thousands of very
very wealthy people they love God as
much as any of you Pharisees out there
that think you love God
poor people evil some of them some of
them will cut your throat to see if
you'll bleed and some of the most godly
and friendly and hospitable people I've
ever met or people so this idea that
somehow money is the action here the
cause it's not the causal agent the only
thing money does is reveal who you are
it just makes you more of who you
already are if you're arrogant and you
get money you become unbelievably
unbearably arrogant and so on name any
positive or negative character trait and
then you get money and it exposes that
and expands that and magnifies that
that's what you find out there and
that's why I wrote that book the legacy
journey it's the only book I've ever
written on wealth all the other books
have written their own money and there's
a difference and it's the most Christian
book I've ever written if you don't want
to read something that's quoting your
scripture and I don't like the Christian
Dave Ramsey want you don't like the Dave
Ramsey because that's good be is but
anyway I give that's always humorous to
me wanna see it on social media all
right Dave Ramsey said for that
Christian stuff it's kind of like you
can't you know it's like I like
Chevrolet cars except for the Chevrolet
part you know I mean it's got a dumb
statement you know but anyway I've only
written one book that was a Christian
book and a wealth book and that is the
legacy journey and it outlines the stuff
I'm talking about here